[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bernard vertes en mer allez merci
bernard est avec nous pardon je pars
lancé le truc c'est quoi le petit voile
qui l'a surpris
[Applaudissements]
il est très fort sur tee shirt gris
chose en dessous qui va exactement ont
commencé avec les 24 heures tv allez on
y va
j'ai pas vu un gars sourire dans cette
émission route depuis un mois il fallait
absolument pas rater heure par heure au
cours de ces dernières 24 heures sur
cela c'est un peu mytho pas j'étais pas
là la semaine dernière désolé vous
pouvez me follow sur twitter je m'en
bats les regards est parti à 12h30 on a
regardé du rugby sur france 2 on a
croisé une vedette de la téloche
isabelle coup là
j'ai regardé le jt j'ai vu de lapsus de
jean-baptiste marteau vu son lapsus
on a une idée de ce qui se passe au
village olympique la nuit bonjour
grégory naboulet faisait pour direct
avec notre corée du sud
bon les français la nuit ça pas été
terrible pour eux
la nuit puis j'ai beaucoup regardé m6
hier dans le 19 45 ils ont fait un sujet
sur les coulisses de météo france on en
a appris beaucoup peut-être même un peu
trop sur l'ensemble du réseau éviter la
surcharge pour éviter le risque de black
est ce qu'ils ont envie de flouter donc
on peut vous donner tous les login pour
vous connecter au serveur de m france en
2016 et login météorage a aujourd'hui à
23h35 j'ai regardé bernard sur m6 et
vous avez suivi le quotidien de notre
boulangerie préférée celle où j'en ai
écrit là car l'amérique est incollable
sur ses pâtisseries mme c'est lui qui
les inventer un truc bollain santal de
boîte et d'ailleurs on a trouvé le
voleur qui ne fera jamais enquête
exclusive à mon avis vu son niveau pour
pétards un autoradio niang
non
y a pas de victimes site qui doit partir
mais c'est parce que je reste mais je
vais partir comme intel et pour faire
chier je lui dis mon fils adore méthane
en fait les beaux moments et qu'on est
que dans c dans l'air bon vous savez
peut-être pas mais j'étais absent
quelques jours parce que je me suis
rendu à paire de tongs pour les épreuves
de patinage joie que connaît rien qui
s'est décousu mater la cérémonie de
clôture suivi par première question suit
parcourir mais en droit comme en 2003
mais a vu ça concerne 40 t know millions
de français 41 et regio question médias
la voix lasse et 72% des populations qui
ont regardé les jo non mais c'est quoi
la caissière 40% france ont regardé au
moins une minute legio pendant les jo et
ouais j'en 12%
info de média tu me reproches une fois
la cérémonie de clôture les coréens ont
mis le paquet niveau budget regardant
l'a vu plein de choses on a vu dans un
monde de dan dans les tribunes des
lumières tous les sportifs présents des
drapeaux partout on a eu sur une loi un
remake de dirty dancing
les coréens ont aussi voulu rendre
hommage à klaus et ça fait plaisir ça
amène laurent voulzy qui a tenu à être
présent pour finir le spectacle on a
tous cérémonie ils ont fait chanter un
enfant de huit ans qu'on entend dans
tout le stade sans micro bravo à eux
visiblement il a choisi sa team
m
on dit
le moment qu'on attendait tous étaient
bien sûr le moment où la flamme s'éteint
on sait d'ailleurs comment ils ont
réussi à éteindre les flammes aussi
énorme aussi vite
[Musique]
il aura fallu attendre le dernier jour
des épreuves pour trouver le moment le
plus malesan de ces jeux on sait pas si
c'est le papa ou la maman
comme quoi même en freestyle on est un
peu l'esprit cafistes bon ça c'est la
maman âgée a plutôt le père je sais de
façon on va vérifier
[Applaudissements]
on continue rapidement de petits pois
c'était le week end ça s'est fini à
tickets combinés à la cloture n'y ont
pas droit dans la place on est pressé
que ça revienne mais c'est qu'ils me de
français les ont fini ce taux bout du
rouleau
alors bien sûr un burn-out céline géraud
déjà sait plus où aller sur le plateau
elle sait plus où elle en est la petite
candeloro aller en attendant je vous
propose tout simplement de repartir
du côté pop du patinage podium du
patinage par barret fond patrick montel
bus sont là dessus si tu sens qu'il a
aussi un petit peu besoin de vacances
patoche c'est normal il ya aucune image
du ski de fond
pourquoi comme ça qu'on va sucer cité
par des vocations caucase
on a tendance à l'oublier mais y'a une
femme entre nelson monfort et philippe
candeloro elle s'appelle annick dumont
et la police précise chouïa trop ce qui
comprend ce crédit peut bosser au cnrs
oui oui record du monde du libre et
records du monde des deux épreuves la
danse courte et le libre record du monde
battu d'abord par les français est il
passé avant et puis roi battu sur le
général par les canadiens qui aussi 28
le record de la danse courte détenus par
les canadiens pour le programme pub est
détenu par les français pour le proche
avenir
matt est tenu par les français pour le
général est battue par les canadiens
pour général
hier black de philippe candeloro plus
personne n'écoute dans la patinoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sacha qui n'était pas du chiisme
quand on est obligé de parler de celui
qui a marqué de son empreinte les jo
martin fourcade mais patrick montel
champion des pronostics fois réalisateur
tim herlihy j'adore
[Musique]
l'entraînement libyen
il est bien
ma foi je voulais ce truc comme tu veux
un dernier truc qu il y avait quand même
l'om psg
garçons 1 fille nahla charaf des princes
pas le temps de parler du résultat
malheureusement partie stade et j'ai
pensé à toi hier soir 3-0 bras c'est
mérité et on est parti de notre caméra
au stade pour recueillir l'ambiance à
quelques minutes du match regardez on a
croisé plein de supporters parisiens
très sympa franchement motivé quant au
hasard d'une allée à débarquer tout d'un
conte sans crier gare un supporters caf
un cri qu'on ne s'explique toujours pas
24 heures après 5,0 pourquoi rue
tranquille la route chine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a basculé dans un autre univers voulu
proposer aux supporters d'échanger leur
place pour le clasico contre un dîner
romantique avec leur chéri et j'espère
que leur chérie avait un plan b pour la
soirée en garde les places je prends les
places mort on est plein cela madame
elle mange très bien lorsqu'elle est pas
un restaurant c'est dur à papa de six
jours sinon rien du tout joué
aujourd'hui mais ce club luxe avec votre
chien oui en échange vous donner les
places qu'est ce qu'on fait on a fait
notre jeu préféré le jeudi dès lors à
super simple c'est un supporters enfile
le maillot de neymar les yeux bandés en
moins de 10 secondes il gagne le maillot
sauf qu'on le remplace par un maillot de
l'om c'est une autre ambiance il adore
voilà ma jane tripot tout on est là bas
on est là bas mon père est mon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon pas non mais non un gamin
il
il a gagné ou pas vous êtes des buts
bien sûr on préférerait ont fini avec sa
celui qui met 11 ans a seul compte que
c'est pas le maillot de neymar dans son
regard à la fin tu sens qu'il vit la
blague comme une trahison
[Musique]
allez paris marie dans le cas contraire
ça bouge pas allez paris ici à paris ça
bouge pas ce soir c'est pour nous merci
c'est gentil merci camille lacourt avait
très peur du chômage
camille commun